Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new black panther 2 namor video you probably
saw the news recently there were some websites
announcing that namor was actually going to be
the main villain of the film so i'll explain
what's going on with that what it means for
the future of the mcu because namor is a mutant
he's literally referred to in marvel comics as the
first mutant so i'll explain why that is because
technically apocalypse is older and now this sort
of fits into the overall plan for marvel phase
four but if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos they're
going to be filming the movie really soon and
we have loki episodes that are starting tonight
that's right midnight tonight i'll be posting my
loki episode 1 video early tomorrow on wednesday
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just let me know what you want them to do with the
black panther movies going forward even though
we have really big movies like the fantastic
four movie coming out after black panther two a
lot of people are pointing to black panther two
which is now titled wakanda forever as being one
of the big turning points of marvel phase four
when we transition to marvel phase five and you
start to see more legit mutants popping up in the
mcu like some of the big fox x-men characters
showing up in the marvel cinematic universe
but if you didn't see the news the past couple of
days the luminer was the one that was reporting
this initially they're the ones that broke the
news and usually they've been pretty accurate
in the past about stuff like this so addressing
the whole issue of chadwick boseman passing away
and how they may or may not have changed the
plot of the film kevin feige and ryan coogler
have been talking about a lot how the movie will
handle the issue of chadwick boseman passing away
and he's still supposed to be a huge part of
the plot and critical to how the story plays out
namor is a really easy way to do that just because
of their rivalry in the comics and i will explain
why they are rivals what happened to set that off
in the comics and obviously some of the references
that we've seen to namor in the mcu so far namor
and atlanta's because they've already canonized
those characters to the mcu but if it wasn't clear
kevin feige did confirm a long time ago that they
weren't going to recast the role of t'challa
but notice that he said not recasting t'challa
they didn't say that they weren't recasting
black panther that's because in the comics and
in the mcu already they've canonized that the
black panther is a mantle that is passed down
usually it's done to each new king of wakanda
and when they become king it serves as sort of
a dual role you take the throne of wakanda and
the mantle of black panther at the same time
the difference in the mcu is that when the
events of captain america civil war pick up
king tachaka had already passed down the mantle
of black panther to t'challa even though he
himself was still king at the time obviously
before he gets assassinated by baron zemo
so that was a bit of an exception usually you
become black panther and the new king of wakanda
at the same time but the new site that broke this
neymar news said that tina cuerta the mexican
actor who marvel previously confirmed was going to
be a mystery villain in the movie was the person
who was secretly going to be playing the name
or character and they named a couple of other
new characters being cast around him as other
versions of atlanteans they reported the movie
as casting some north and south american actors
of indigenous backgrounds as two mayan characters
being referred to as ziana and kadmael and they're
claiming that those are meant to be code names for
neymar's cousin neymora in another major atlantean
warlord character from the comics named atuma
so it makes sense that if marvel wanted to do
a version of namor and a version of atlantis
they would want it to visually look very
different from dc's version of atlantis and
atlanteans so you don't have a lot of people being
confused comparing it to dc's version of aquaman
and there is some historical basis for them tying
the mayans for example to atlantis and some other
ancient cultures speaking of which talking about
ancient cultures talking about connections to the
eternals movie which we're getting ready to see
this november in the history of atlantis in the
mcu the eternals movie mostly starts with them
in mesopotamia here in the trailer the cradle of
real world civilization just based on some real
world facts but because the movie goes back
thousands of years in earth's history we could
see them reference atlantis before it sunk into
the ocean off the coast of africa atlantis in the
mcu was canonized over here on nick fury's map way
back as early as iron man 2 and they referenced it
again during that big avengers end game scene when
okoye is reporting on the quote-unquote underwater
earthquake that wakanda is just going to ignore
reading on those tremors it was a mild
subduction under the african plate
do we have a visual how are we handling it nat
it's an earthquake under the ocean we handle it
by not handling it at the time everyone was
watching this in the theater most everyone kind of
assumed it was meant to foreshadow or set up some
future conflict between namor and black panther
that they'd pay off in one of the black panther
sequel movies or some other avengers movie it
was just a question of when and how they would pay
it off then a while later the writers of the movie
marcus and mcfeely said that when they wrote that
reference that particular scene sometimes they
said they plant seeds and they grow into something
big what they meant by that is that just because
they wrote a name or reference into avengers
end game that didn't automatically mean that ron
coogler would be shackled to paying off namor in
black panther 2 when they came time to make that
it just means that he had the option to do that
if you wanted like we're going to give this to
you you can use it if you want to kevin feige the
other marvel directors have said in the past that
they do have some larger story elements and beats
planned out many years in advance like thanos and
the infinity gauntlet they knew that really early
on but a lot of the stuff about the villains that
they use along the way the smaller story beats the
way they connect things typically change along the
way for instance we're getting ready to see doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness sam raimi is
directing it's going to be this huge big crossover
movie but initially scott derrickson before he
left the project had very different plans for what
the movie was going to be so he and kevin feige
just had a big disagreement and he decided to
leave the project and i know we're getting ready
for loki episodes but kevin feige was so impressed
with the show runner on loki who had come off
of rick and morty they hired the showrunner
of loki to write the doctor strange 2 movie
for sam raimi so he said that when he did that
they did a page one ground-up rewrite so whatever
the movie was going to be before sam raimi came on
to doctor strange to it was completely different
so just a good example of how marvel movies along
the way can change dramatically even though they
already have big story beats planned out like
they've known who the major overall villain of
marvel phase 4 is going to be for a long time
now i don't know if ryan coogler had always
planned on using namor as the main villain before
chadwick boseman passed away but they have such
a rich rivalry in the comics that goes back many
years namor was just one of the first big mutant
characters that everyone was talking about after
avengers end game like he would be an amazing
black panther two villain just near the top of
most people's lists real easy slam dunk on a story
level for a number of different reasons and one
of them is that now namor can help them solve the
issue of chadwick boseman's passing on a story
level you just make namor responsible for the
death of black panther at the beginning of the
movie and you have it be retaliation for wakanda
not coming to their aid after thanos snapped the
infinity gauntlet in avengers infinity war but
the reason why black panther and neymar have this
epic feud in the comics it actually goes way back
to t'challa's childhood when he and neymar teamed
up to track down some wakandan criminals that had
fled to atlantis he gets the sense that atlantis
is going to be powerful enough to become this real
threat to wakanda because wakanda up to this point
had been thought to be the most advanced society
on the planet so who could possibly threaten them
well big surprise atlantis is also one of the most
advanced societies on the planet they've just been
hidden at the bottom of the ocean this whole time
then it really didn't turn to all-out war till
later in avengers vs x-men which is actually
a more recent comic book they have their first
actual battle between wakanda and atlantis the
phoenix force inhabits five different mutants and
one of them is neymar neymar goes a little bit
drunk with power and decides that he has a duty
to invade wakanda because he thinks that they're
harboring atlantean criminals shuri herself later
retaliates by invading atlantis with a bunch of
wakandans killing a bunch of their people and
namor treats this like an escalation and it
goes to full-blown war then if you remember the
avengers time runs out storyline where you have
the illuminati the avengers trying to save earth
from the destruction of the entire multiverse
neymar winds up defecting to thanos's cabal
which is like the evil version of the illuminati
even though the illuminati is made up of the
biggest marvel hero characters they make a lot of
really shady decisions themselves too so it's all
shades of grey but neymar uses the chaos of what's
happening in the cabal to invade wakanda on the dl
massacring even more of their people devastating
their country after which black panther finally
kills him then tosses him into a parallel universe
just as it's about to be destroyed and that was
all in the lead up to marvel's secret wars event
in no spoilers or anything but there is some big
stuff happening this week in the marvel cinematic
universe that references marvel's secret wars
happening in the future so i'll do a separate
video about secret wars easter eggs later this
week almost everyone the russo brothers have
been talking about avengers secret wars down the
road how it'd be a really cool story arc to do but
it just take marvel a while to build up to that
so it does sound like they're setting the seeds
for secret wars like that's why marvel phase
4 is treadling so heavily on the multiverse
because secret wars is a big multiverse event even
though the term secret wars refers to a couple of
different comic book arcs there's the beyonders
secret wars from the 80s and then there's the more
modern multiverse secret war story i'm talking
about the more modern multiverse story but also
sort of talking about the look of atlanteans if
these really are going to be atlanteans in the
mcu when you talk about connections to the mayans
there are some real world connections you can make
to that because in history thousands of years ago
the mayan culture had advanced technology that was
way beyond what you saw from other places in the
world then they slowly abandoned their cities and
sort of vanished off the map so to speak later
we learned why that was it was mostly because of
climate change like all the fertile grounds where
they grew their crops around their cities started
to go dry so they had to abandon their cities
but you could see how you could tie that to the
history of atlantis like the atlanteans were this
ancient advanced culture that suddenly vanished
off the face of the map when really atlantis just
sank to the bottom of the ocean and then they
were slowly mutated over time to look like this
neymar himself is half atlantean but he is king
of atlantis just like aquaman as king of atlantis
the reason why he's called the first mutant is
because he debuted first in the comics as a mutant
character so marvel calls him the first mutant
even though within the context of the marvel
storyline like the main marvel timeline if you're
talking about the oldest mutant apocalypse is
technically the oldest mutant there's also a big
connection between apocalypse and the celestials
too so even though we're probably not going to see
apocalypse inside the mcu for a long long time
i will talk about him when i do more eternals
videos so everything is connected but everybody
just let me know in the comments what you think
about the idea of this tina cuerta actor playing
namor in the mcu but my next big video will be my
full loki episode 1 video so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of that and i'll just continue the disney
plus giveaway in my loki episode videos everyone
click here for my loki episode 1 early review
video and click here for my big new eternals
trailer video for kit harington's black knight
character and his future in the avengers movies
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!